hi
my name is bryce mendelssohn and i'm a
clinical genetics fellow at uc san
francisco it's my pleasure to introduce
the keynote
talk today at the bio conference live
genetics and genomics conference
entitled individualized genomic medicine
update
um it is my pleasure to introduce dr
robert nussbaum
he is the holly smith professor of
medicine at ucsf the chief of the
division of genomic medicine and he
needs both the cancer risk program at
the helen diller family cancer center
and the ucsf program in cardiovascular
genetics
his research complement accomplishments
include identification of alpha
synuclein as the first gene to cause a
familiar form of parkinson's disease
he's the co-author of 190 peer-reviewed
publications and the author of a popular
textbook in human genetics thompson and
thompson's genetics and medicine dr
nussbaum has been on the board of
directors of the american college of
medical genetics and the american
society of human genetics for which he
has also served as president
and he was elected to the institute of
medicine in 2004.
newsbomb i look forward to your talk
hi welcome back we're going to
work on the sound for a moment if you
would
um
if you would congratulate with us with
your patience thank you
okay so uh can you hear me now i'm
apologize for the
uh problem with the sound but this
should be now uh straightened out
so uh the talk today i'm going to be
reviewing what is individualized
medicine i'm going to talk about some
myths that seem to have
been been floating around about the use
of genomics in medicine and what the app
current applications and
future applications might be
i'd like particularly to focus on a
useful framework for thinking about how
one uses genomics as a
for testing purposes in medicine and
introducing what's called the ace
framework the acce framework and then
i'll be running through some examples as
well
so what is individualized medicine uh to
quote francis collins who's a current
nih director and its most basic
individualized medicine refers to using
information about a person's genetic
makeup to tailor strategies for the
detection treatment or prevention of
disease
now there are a bunch of myths that i
think we
are currently in having to deal with in
the use of genomics to individualize
medicine the first is that
basic research findings are easily and
quickly translatable into clinical
applications this is a myth
just because one is doing research on
humans that doesn't necessarily mean
that the information is immediately
usable for clinical
reasons in human beings
second myth is that genomics is so cool
you don't need to gather the effect of
this data needed for the translation
pathway this is another uh problem that
we're facing and that is uh the need to
develop evidence to show that when
genomics is used to individualize
medicine it improves patient care
the third issue and one that we are all
grappling with is that the patient and
the providers of genomic testing they
get to decide what's useful and the
third party payers and the governments
are that pay for health care are
delighted to pay for it and this uh of
course we all know is not true and
finally that complete genomic sequencing
as opposed to
partial sequencing such as exomes etc
are going to solve all these problems
this also is not the case there's still
a lot of issues that are medical
social and economic around this area
so let's talk about genomic analysis
across the life span preconception
prenatal
newborns
children
and adults
and we can start
with thinking about
the uh
the fact that
when
you have
a
an issue
with uh doing genetic testing
in addition to finding particular
variation that you're looking for in
order to try to explain let's say a
particular disorder you also
if you do broad genomic analysis of
sequencing we're also going to find what
are called incidental findings these are
changes that are seen in the genome that
are not directly what you were asking
about but still will need to be
addressed
and considered when found
next uh in our discussion
is to go over what i call the ace
framework and this is based on the work
from moon curry who established the
center for disease control office of
public health genomics and i find this
to be a very valuable framework for
thinking about testing
and that is to break the
particular issues down to four areas a c
c and e the a being analytical validity
which means do we have the right result
from the right patient
and in particular is this test sensitive
specific and accurate
clinical validity is slightly different
i'm going to be stressing the difference
between analytical and clinical validity
in just a few minutes but clinical
validity is really the ability of a
genetic test to predict whether someone
is at risk or actually has a particular
disorder
in genetics we often refer to this as
the penetrance given a particular set of
genetic variants how how frequently does
such a person either have or will
develop a genetic disease in other parts
of medicine we call this the positive
predictive value given a test what's the
risk of developing the disease you also
have the negative predictive value which
in medicine is often referred to as the
rule out if you don't have a positive
test if you have a negative test how
likely is it that you are free of the
disease that you don't have the disease
or you will not develop the disease with
any increased frequency over that of
anyone else in the general population
the third c
the third step i'm sorry the second c is
clinical utility
even if a test is analytically valid and
is predictive
how useful is it to the patient and the
doctor to have that test result and
clinical utility is one of the key areas
where we really need to develop evidence
and finally there's the e which stands
for ethical legal and social
implications of the work
is there value to society to having
particular test results even if they're
valid
in both on the analytical and clinical
side and even if the patient or even the
doctor thinks it's useful to have the
test result
is society
willing to pay for it
so clinical validity which we also think
of
as uh positive and negative predicted
value so what is the positive predictive
value it's the fraction of people with a
particular variant which could be a
change in in one copy of a gene
or change in both copies of a gene
because as you know
all genes except those on the x
chromosome in men come in pairs you get
one from your father and one from your
mother what we call the genotype is the
pair of variants
that are present in a particular gene
and then finally the haplotype which is
variants that are occurring on one
chromosome but in different genes that
you usually neighboring close by so
multiple variants on one chromosome
genotypes are two variants on both
chromosomes and allele is one variant on
one chromosome so positive predicted
values the fraction of people with a
variant who have or will develop disease
and the other side of this coin is the
negative predictive value the fraction
of people without a particular variant
who do not have or will not develop the
disease so if you think of
the clinical validity that's where we
are i have not gone over analytical
validity at all it's a more of a
technical issue involving tests and
making sure that a blood sample drawn
from patient uh abc actually gets
labeled properly and gets followed
through the laboratory with the correct
label on it and that the result is tied
to the correct patient and that's a
these are technical issues that are very
important but we don't need to talk
about this morning
so if we think about positive predictive
value negative particular value i would
like to uh contrast them with two other
related terms called sensitivity and
specificity these are frequently
confused and i don't want you to confuse
them now sensitivity is in people with a
disease
how often is the test positive so this
is really a
function of the quality of the test it's
it's a it's a specific characteristic of
a test
specificity is the same way in people
without the disease how often is the
test negative in other words can the
test be positive in people in whom it
shouldn't be positive so-called false
positive results these are both
characteristics of a test but a positive
predictive value is in people with a
positive test how often is the disease
present you can see it's sort of the
reverse
of sensitivity and the negative
predictive value is in people with a
negative test how often is the disease
absent
the positive and negative predictive
values
are not strictly characteristics of a
test they are the characteristics of a
test as applied to a population
and that's the main difference
sensitivity and specificity are about a
test the positive and negative values
are about how a test
behaves when applied to a particular
population so here's an example
here suppose you have a test that has a
sensitivity or true positive fraction of
the point 0.9 or 90 that means 90
percent of people have this disease
will show a positive test and the
specificity or true negative fraction is
95 in other words
95 percent of the people who don't have
the disease will show a negative test so
there's a five percent false positive
rate people who don't have the disease
still showing a positive test now that
same test applied to three different
populations where the disease prevalence
the frequency of the disease is either
one percent of the population 0.1
percent of the population or 0.01
percent of the population 100
in ten thousand people you get different
positive predictive values so you can
see this what looks like a very nice and
specific test
ninety-five percent of people who have
who do not have the disease will give
you a negative test only five percent of
the population who don't have the
disease will give you a positive test
when applied to a population where the
disease is rarer and rarer those
false positives start swamping out all
the true positives and so the positive
predicted value starts to fall so for
example if only one in
uh 10 000 people have this disease and
you apply this test
99.8
of all the positive tests you get will
be false positives these patients will
not have the disease
okay so sensitivity and specificity are
intrinsic characteristics of a test
while positive and negative predictive
values are characteristics as applied to
a population and the prevalence of a
disease makes a big difference to the
positive and negative predictive value
now let's talk about some other examples
of genome analysis across the lifespan
and why
the ace framework and why the
sensitivity versus positive value is
important
let's talk about
diagnostics
so in diagnostics we have
a serious problem
it's a clinical validity problem
the ability to predict
uh whether someone is going to be
affected with with a disease given they
have a
what we think of as a positive test and
that clinical validity problem is
focused around the issue of variant
interpretation
and what i mean by that is the following
we can sequence genes and we can find
differences in people's genes of one to
another
i'd just like to take a make a side
comment here make sure you all recognize
i'm sure it's all familiar to you
that there is no such thing as a perfect
human genome there's no such thing as a
control human genome
or or if you want to borrow a phrase
from the geneticists who work on fruit
flies there is no wild type human genome
although sometimes it occurred to me
it'd be sort of nice to think that
someone has a wild a wild type
genome but that doesn't exist
we only know differences between
any one individual's genome and some
sort of a consensus
reference genome that we think
contains the most common uh
sequence throughout the entire genome
of human beings and with ethnic
differences and with with a whole
variety of of differences we know that
this is a
a fiction there is no real reference
genome it's an attempt to create a
baseline against which any one patient's
human dna sequence can be compared and
the problem is
that if you take any one individual's
human genome and sequence it from one
end to the other you'll find between
three and four million differences in
that person's genome
compared to the reference
i mean think of three or four million if
you just
focus your attention on the one to two
percent of the human genome that
contains coding sequence this the parts
of the genome that actually
serve as blueprints for proteins you
still have tens of thousands of
differences with a reference well how
many of them mean anything how many of
them actually have a positive predictive
value for a disease
the fact is we actually don't know
for many of these variants
uh so for example uh how do we
even try to interpret variance
we try to figure out whether varian is
pathogenic or disease-causing we use a
variety of criteria
none of which are absolutely con
confirmatory they're all circumstantial
we try to build a circumstantial case
for a variant being disease-causing so
for example
is it absent or extremely rare in a
large control population of some sort
we would think that a very common
variant is unlikely to have a high risk
of developing disease of causing disease
because if that were the case this
disease would be rampant in the
population
second
does the variant
result in a severe damage to gene
function and we can often predict that
just by looking at the gene sequence
change
does it cause a premature stop in other
words put a punctuation mark into this
gene and make it stop
well before it's supposed to
complete or is it simply a uh change
that substitutes one amino acid in the
protein for another
these are differences which one can uh
infer from looking at sequence
does it follow the inheritance of the
disease in a in a family if it's a
disorder where if you carry a gene
variant you have a high risk of
developing disease and there are many
people in the family with that disease
can you track it and show that everyone
with a disorder now also has the varium
and does it do it in lots of people more
than 10 times or
fewer people
you can also ask if there's an amino
acid change
the
uh was that amino acid conserved
in other words in the same protein but
now
when found in other mammals are found in
birds or fish
is that amino acid changed or unchanged
in other words what will mother nature
tolerate
for a variation at that site and we try
to put all this information together
to try to get some idea and if we have
less evidence
than what i
than the pathogenic we use a term called
likely pathogenic but unfortunately
there are many variants where we can
call them neither variant pathogenic or
likely pathogenic
and we also can't rule it out as being
completely benign
that it's just a variation like eye
color
so we're stuck in the middle and there
are many variants where we're stuck in
the middle with this so-called
inconclusive result and these are called
variants of uncertain significance so
here's a some data from a paper that was
published in april 2014 looking at
hereditary cancer families using a large
panel of genes this could be anywhere
from 12 to 15 16 different genes that
are being tested now there are some
panels that are up over 40 genes
that cause hereditary cancer and what
we're doing is
is is
applying this panel to an individual
into a family where there appears to be
some kind of hereditary cancer but we
don't know exactly what type we're not
sure so we do a broad panel and ask is
there a in any one of a dove a few dozen
genes
and what this shows you is
that somewhere between 65 up to 73 of
the time we don't find any variation
that is suspicious of being uh causative
of hereditary cancer and
somewhere between 7.2 and 9.8 between 7
and 10 percent of the time we actually
find a smoking gun and we find a variant
that we're quite confident is
disease-causing but you can see in
between we have between 15 up to 25 26
percent of the time we find the change
but we don't know what it means it's
inconclusive and this is a real problem
for
screening uh
and for diagnostics because uh you will
end up
as you add more and more genes to a
panel to try to expand the the
set of genes that you're evaluating
you are
simply by the numbers are going to start
finding more and more variation because
there's so much variation in the genome
anyway
and this variation may be difficult to
interpret and so we're left with
test results where the doctors and the
patients have to really live with
uncertainty they don't know whether a
particular variation is important or not
however i should also mention that this
approach can be very successful this was
a paper published last year from baylor
college of medicine
in the new england journal of medicine
where they reported 250 consecutive
patients with undiagnosed diseases
undiagnosed diseases are essentially
disorders where we have a high suspicion
that there's a genetic disorder based on
the presentation the family history a
whole variety of of clinical clues
would make a clinician very suspicious
that this is a genetic problem
and instead of being able to make a
diagnosis these patients have gone
to variety of doctors have had a whole
variety of different sorts of blood
tests and x-rays etc and no diagnosis
has been made and the bottom line for
this
is that of those these are 250 patients
that were reported they cover the whole
gamut
from prenatal to adult in age the type
of disorders
many of them have neurological disorders
as well as other organ system disorders
and that's not
a surprise because the suspicion that
these were genetic was based to a large
extent on what their clinical picture
was but they may have had other sorts of
disorders or even disorders not
affecting the nervous system so you can
see that it's a pretty broad swath with
an emphasis on neurological disorders
and certainly covering the whole uh age
range and what was found was a total of
62 out of 250 or just about 25
percent they were able to make a
definite positive diagnosis by doing uh
sequencing of a whole exome in other
words all one the one to two percent of
the human genome that codes for proteins
without any prior um
decision about what gene was likely to
be affected and what's interesting of
these 62
almost half were new mutations not
present in either parent and this is now
becoming
although this is a well-known phenomenon
i think the extent to which these
puzzling
undiagnosed diseases particularly
involving children
that
turn out to be due to a new change in
the gene that neither parent carries
and this of course has important
important implications if we think about
using carrier testing to affect genetic
disease half of the time some of these
severe disorders you will not find the
variant in the parent because it
occurred new in the child
another interesting aspect of this
is that four of the 62 patients who
for whom a diagnosis was made turns out
had two disorders
at the same time
and this probably is contributed to our
failure to be able to make a diagnosis
in these patients
it's because the two disorders
were thought to be one
and that
the fusion or the union of these two
different disorders then presented a
clinical picture that was very puzzling
it didn't fit any pattern and it didn't
fit a pattern because it wasn't a
pattern it was two patterns fused
together
so
a couple of key concepts i'd like to
also introduce which is
if a person has a disorder and you're
trying to make a diagnosis that's quite
different from doing genetic testing or
genomes sequencing to screen for
problems in an otherwise healthy person
and why is that different
it's different because
if you remember back to positive
predictive and negative predictive
values
the likelihood of there being a disorder
present in the population the prior
probability plays a big role in your
ability to be able to predict whether
any particular variant causes disease
and if you have a patient who has a
neurological disorder and you find a
variation in a gene that is known for a
variety of reasons
from basic research for example to
affect brain development
the chance that that variation is
important and perhaps plays a role in
that child's illness is very different
than if you find some other variant in
the same gene in an otherwise healthy
individual
so i think it's very important to make a
distinction between diagnosis and
screening
second is the difference between what we
call incidental findings and secondary
findings an incidental finding is
something that you weren't looking for
so for example in these undiagnosed
disease cases suppose you find in a
child with a neurological disorder a
mutation in the gene that causes adult
onset
colon cancer
and it does not cause the neurological
problem that the child has you've
essentially stumbled on a significant
finding but you stumbled on it you
certainly were not looking for it
and that would be different from saying
okay
in the undiagnosed disease setting
not only are you trying to make a
diagnosis but there is a set of other
genetic changes which you ought to look
for because they're important to know
about even if they don't explain the
child's diagnosis these would be changes
that would cause an adult disorder that
you could intervene on that you could
prevent that you could ameliorate
something that it would be worth knowing
about even though it doesn't explain the
diagnosis and that set of findings we
call secondary
uh findings so as you expand
the number of genes in the diagnostic
setting
you are going to start
stumbling on things and you also um
there will likely be and there are
recommendations now coming out from the
variety of genetic uh
provider groups like the american
college of medical genetics and genomics
that there are certain secondary
findings that you really ought to look
for of course in screening
there are no incidental findings
and in fact there is no there are no
secondary findings because you're not
trying to diagnose a problem and you're
not stumbling on something that's
irrelevant to the reason for doing the
test
if you do the test for screening
purposes
everything in essence
is incidental or secondary
or nothing you find is incidental and
secondary
okay
so uh
incidental and secondary findings for
example which genes and which mutations
should be included in
as part of incidental and secondary
findings so in a patient undergoing
whole exome analysis for developmental
delay should you seek
mutations that cause hereditary breast
cancer in the adult that would be a
secondary or should you report mutations
you stumble on which would be incidental
findings what do you do if you find
variants where you actually don't know
whether they're pathogenic in other
words they're variants of uncertain
significance
should those be reported
these are really uh important issues
that are being dealt with and discussed
with a certain amount of heat and and
some light uh in the currently in the
genetics
provider community
and the american college of medical
genetics has recommended uh currently
that there are 56 genes that should be
reported if pathogenic mutations are
found
so these would be constituting secondary
findings
um
if you've done a whole exome or whole
genome analysis for any reason because
they represent a threat to health
they're not evident during routine
health care and useful interventions are
possible in other words there's value in
knowing these this set of 56 genes will
almost certainly change
will grow
will be pruned and will change over time
why because the number of useful
interventions we have are going to
increase over time
another area
that we can talk about
is
screening
of in adults to prevent
serious adverse reactions so this is now
not someone in whom you're trying to
make diagnosis what you're doing is
you're screening and the
poster child from this one of the best
examples of this is in the area of
pharmacogenetics the genetics that
contribute to the effect and the impact
of drug treatment
so there's a particular
tissue type this is the hla which is the
region that
the that the
body uses to determine what is self and
what's not self it's what has to be
matched when you're doing some sort of a
transplant
well it turns out that there are certain
immune
variation at the hla
position
that have a very high positive
predictive value for whether you're
going to have a severe skin reaction to
a
anti-retroviral drug called the
baccavier and it's particularly the
hlab-5701
variant
and so there was a study done where they
looked at almost 2 000 patients with an
hiv infection who had not previously
received the back revere and they were
randomly assigned to undergo the
screening or just to receive standard of
care
and what was found
was that in the predominantly white
population where the hlab 5701 is much
more common it's a much rarer allele in
other populations
whereas there are other
hla
alleles or hla variants
that predispose to bad reactions with
other drugs that are more common in
other ethnic groups so there's nothing
special about about the white
populations except that 5701 happens to
be more common among white populations
so 94 of the patients who did not carry
this
do not carry this and none of them had a
hypersensitivity reaction to a back of
your in other words the negative
predictive value of not having hla b5701
was 100
you would not get the negative skin
reaction if you did not have this
variant whereas the six percent of
individuals who did carry this variant
were at a 50 percent risk for this
hypersensitivity reaction a positive
predicted value of 50 percent for a
severe skin reaction so here we have a
pharmacogenic test that can be used to
prevent a specific toxic effect of a
drug and this has to be determined
through essentially a screening test
you're going to screen people to see if
they carry this variant
this study was published in february 7
2008
and
within almost a one year february 19
2009 there was a
statement in the journal the american
medical association from the
international aid society saying screen
for this
and don't use a back of here if you're
hla b5701
what the reason i point this out is what
it shows
is that one year after the data were
available
the recommendations came through
not to apply this piece of information
now i think some of you may say why it
take a whole year and other others of
you might say one only one year that's
very fast
in the medical area i would say this is
actually quite fast
it might be um intolerably slow in the
um
in the world of
silicon valley uh but in in medicine to
have a recommendation go from
a uh
evidence to a straight recommendation is
that in one year is actually quite fast
now here's another example of of genetic
testing that has much lower
positive predictive value and these are
what are called association tests where
you look at a group of people have a
disease and a group of people who don't
have a disease and ask is there any
change in their genome that is
statistically significantly
present more frequently in the people
with the disease and the people without
so here's a particular change
unfortunately it has a very clunky
nomenclature but it's called
rs10757274 which is a change that occurs
on chromosome 9
it was found to be increased in people
with coronary artery disease that's what
cad is
and if people who had the aaa on their
two chromosome nines if they're
considered to have the baseline
risk of one
no more or less likely to have coronary
disease in the general population then
if you had one copy
of the risk allele or two copies of the
risk allele which is g
you went from 1 to 1.25 to 1.38 so this
is a slightly increased about a 1.4 fold
increased risk
of having coronary artery disease
compared to the general population
but what happens when you apply this to
i'm going to skip through this because
it's a
just background information let's go
right to here what is the positive
predictive value
for these particular variants at that rs
locus i told you about
in the general population if you're 65
years old and you have no coronary
disease risk factors you know you're not
a smoker you don't have hypertension
your lifetime risk over the next 10
years not lifetime over the next 10
years developing coronary artery disease
if you're 65 years old is about 11
if you knew that you had the two risk
alleles instead of being 11 it would be
13.2 percent and if you had zero risk
alleles it'd be 9.2
if you're a 40 year old female with no
risk factors once again two percent over
the next 10 years if you had both risk
alleles 2.4 no risk allele 1.7 so point
i'm trying to make here is that these
numbers don't really change very much
in other words
knowing which alleles are present at
this position
has very little positive predictive
value for coronary disease
and if you say well that's just one
place we've got dozens of variations
that affect this so what is the um
what would be the uh value of combining
a bunch of different uh
risk alleles
and so they looked at 13 of these risk
variations to generate overall risk
score here's the one we've just been
talking about on chromosome 9 this
rs-497 etc which has an average
increased risk of 1.3 and you can see
the others increase your risk by as much
as 1.68 that's probably the largest one
versus one that's as small as only 8 or
1.08 increase but let's combine them all
what happens
so what i want to show you here is let's
look at the fraction of the population
that has
either
coronary heart disease
or no coronary artery disease or
coronary heart disease
and this is a two population so with
with coronary heart disease is in the
blue line and the dotted line is without
and what you're looking at here is a
risk score not based on genetics but
based on what we what came out of the
framingham heart study which is a
intensive decades-long study of risk
factors that affect uh coronary artery
disease things like smoking family
history uh and other things of that sort
so
um
and what you can see
is that the two curves between the
people without
and with coronary disease the dot and
the blue line are very similar but with
perhaps some slight shift to the right
of people who have coronary heart
coronary artery disease
if you use instead of the framingham
score you use the genetic
risk score based on all 13 snips the two
curves are even more overlapping and
this is just another reflection of the
fact that even if you combine all these
and even though they are all
statistically significantly associated
with coronary disease they really do not
um change your overall risk for coronary
disease significantly
and this is the kind of test these uh
variants
that are relatively common in the
population and increase risk by 1.2 1.4
1.5 they're the kind of risk that are
used for a lot of the direct to consumer
testing so here's an example of a test
for type 2 diabetes carried out by one
of my colleagues where she was found to
have a 25 percent lifetime incidence
risk for type 2 diabetes compared to the
average of about 21 percent and i i i
would say you know this is in the eye of
the beholder but i would say that
knowing that one's risk is 25 versus 21
is a very small number and not great
utility the other problem with a lot of
direct to consumer testing
is that it tends not to be reproducible
so these are recommendations from the
center for disease control
does this sort of genomic profiling
using common variants to assess type 2
diabetes risk improve health outcome and
they said that there was completely
insufficient evidence to recommend such
testing for variants in 28 different
positions to assess risk for type 2
diabetes in the general population
that the magnitude of the net health
benefit from these tests alone or in
combination with close to zero they
discourage its clinical use and this of
course is what led to the fda
enforcement for direct to consumer
testing in other words very little
positive predictive value and also
very little utility
here's the problem with reproducibility
is that uh if you compare genetic test
results from different companies
and here's for
six different disorders type 2 diabetes
is here on the bottom prostate cancer is
the one above that age-related macro
degeneration is at the top of the list
and what they essentially asked three
different companies was do you think
that this individual
they gave a dna sample do you think this
individual's risk was increased
decreased or unchanged and there was a
substantial number of people
that
were assigned to different risk carrier
categories by all three companies one
said increased one said no change the
other said decrease when i say
significant anywhere from uh
from um
zero in other words there were no uh for
atrial fibrillation there were no
individuals who were assigned a
different risk category to as high as
nine percent for prostate cancer nine
percent of people had completely
contradictory results coming from the
three different companies
and if you look through this you can see
assign the same risk category by two
companies so for example two said it was
an increased risk for age-related macro
degeneration and one said no change that
was six percent another six percent
one of the companies had increased and
twelve and a half percent two companies
that increased and once it decreased or
the other way around
so there's just um
very poor reproducibility and positive
predictive value which makes this sort
of testing which is why the fda is so
concerned about the clinical validity of
such testing
finally i'm going to go to screening for
preconception and then i'm going to stop
this is a new and growing area which
comes from the idea originally that
there were certain ethnic groups that
had an increased rate of carrying
being carriers for severe disorders that
caused the parents no problem because
they had one normal gene paired with the
abnormal one they were so-called
carriers but if a child were to inherit
two abnormal genes one from each parent
then that child would have a
a severe disorder
and growing from that has become the
thought of well maybe we shouldn't be
restricting it to just a small number of
such
relatively more common disorders in
particular populations so for example
the classic example would be tay sachs
disease among ashkenazi jews or
sickle cell anemia among african
americans or beta thalassemia among
people from mediterranean greek or
sardinian origin
instead of focusing on their ethnicity
and focusing on particular
genes
maybe we should just say
let's just offer testing to everybody
for a large panel
of many many such disorders so here for
example is one commercial testing menu
of over a hundred disorders that you can
be tested for and um as well as your
spouse and then you can address the
issue of whether your child would be at
risk for any one of these disorders
because both you and your spouse were
carriers
and i think this is definitely
a wave
i mean it's it's currently present now
and i think it's even more a wave of the
future of one of the earliest um
adoptions of a widespread genome
screening type approach
similar to the screening that
one can imagine will also be done for
drug results
and there have been a position statement
from the american college of medical
genetics which i don't need to go into
but just that whatever you screen for
it should be ones in which there's
prenatal diagnosis available that they
are
serious disorders that we can be
confident are going to cause a disease
in the child
be careful about adult onset disorders
because we're screening prenatally for
something that will not affect the child
and perhaps what we should do is have
the child have the opportunity to decide
for him or herself later on in life
whether he or she wants to have the test
and so
uh i think what i would like to do at
this point
uh because the time is getting late
is simply to summarize the following
that
um
there are obstacles to applying whole
excellent whole genome sequencing
for
either diagnosis or for
screening the analytical validity
sensitivity and specificity and here the
problem really has to do
with our ability to
detect abnormalities
uh when you do a whole exome sequence
you're not looking at the whole genome
you're only looking at a subset of the
genome and there may be important
changes that are simply missed so people
have to realize and recognize the that
the sensitivity of a test
when you're doing whole whole excellent
sequencing is not
high there are also certain kinds of
mutations that are very difficult to
detect
when with current technology so called
insertion or deletion mutations that are
difficult to detect so
the sensitivity is a is still not as
high as we'd like it to be but it is
certainly getting better over time
the next is the very variance of
uncertain significance that we have
incomplete genotype phenotype
correlation we have incomplete ability
when looking at a variant to be able to
predict whether this is going to cause
disease or not this is the genotype
phenotype correlation we have too many
variants of uncertain significance
in in in most of the genes we look at
another whole area that we have not had
a chance to talk about but really does
need to be addressed is a lack of
electronic decision support
you could easily imagine that this
genetic information is going to
overwhelm practitioners they're going to
have difficulty figuring out what's
important what's not what do i do with
it how shall i act on it
what does this mean for my patient and
we're going to have to do a much better
job of building decision support into
our electronic medical records to allow
practicing physicians to use this
information in a time efficient manner
and then finally we have a lack of
evidence base for utility for many of
these
even if we can accurately predict a
disease risk is there anything we can do
about it and if it's useful to the
patient because the patient says this is
something i want to know
and the doctor says this is something i
want to know because it'll
help me not continue to try to find some
other diagnosis i at least can end the
diagnostic odyssey so it's value
for me
there are often situations where a third
party payer will say yes but will it
change the management of the patient in
any significant way and there i think we
really need to build that so with that
i'm going to summarize
that
we should remember the acce model when
thinking about genetic testing
and uh we're going to
go ahead now and bring this to a close
and take uh questions
so
first i'm going to turn over to
dr mendelsohn
thank you a few
questions to start with that have come
in
thank you very much by the way for that
that great talk
one question is
what studies
do you know of or are there any studies
going on right now that are addressing
any of these evidence challenges that
you discussed such as the need for
evidence for
benefit or change in management
there are studies they're mostly funded
by the national human genome research
institute although there are others that
are also being
studied by corey by the patient-centered
outcomes research institute and others
so one of the areas uh is for example a
large study
going on at vanderbilt university that
is using their database of patients and
uh
patient samples to look at the value of
knowing pharmacogenetic variants and
could we
improve
drug therapy by using the right drug for
the right patient and avoid
uh drug complications if we if we knew
what the genetic variation was in in
patients so that's certainly one large
area where this is being done
there's also quite a few studies going
on now that are looking at
the undiagnosed disease area and what is
the economic benefit of ending the
diagnostic odyssey if we can make a
diagnosis by using genetic
testing early
rather than late
how many unnecessary and expensive tests
could we have avoided those are just two
examples but there are there are others
as well
thank you another question that i've
gotten has to do with the use of genomic
sequencing
in cancer in particular
in enabling
clinicians to use drugs to target
cancers and i think the question had to
do with
along the lines of what you were saying
is how good are those predictive values
when a
a genetic test suggests a particular
cancer therapy um is there a lot of
evidence behind that that that
particular drug will not be effective in
that cancer or is that also an area that
is still still maturing
question
so i'm going to put up a slide about
targeted treatment because i skipped
over this because of time
there are certainly now developing a
whole area of treatment
for cancers it's based on finding
mutations in particular tumors that are
sensitive to highly targeted treatments
so for example the poster child for this
is the use of this drug imatinib brand
name is gleevec that's been used for
chronic myelogenous leukemia which
targets a particular mutant pro mutant
protein that drives the development of
this tumor similarly there's a
monoclonal antibody
called tres tras to zuma or herceptin
which is used for breast cancer patients
that have a amplification of the her2
new
protein so these are the beginnings and
we now have
many other pathways many other specific
targets and many other drugs that are
being developed
i would say that the level of of
evidence for these
tends to be very high because the fda
requires that these drugs be used and
tested in the formal
randomized controlled trials
the main difficulty with these drugs is
the following
that cancer is a very uh shape-shifting
tissue
it's
can undergo gene changes mutations very
easily and so that many of these tumors
when faced with these specific
anti-tumor agents will undergo mutations
which render them
resistant
because you're they're under selection
from these drugs
so many of these drugs have had
remarkable
fantastic initial results but then over
time
the tumor escapes control by these drugs
and what this leads to i think is the
growing idea that
these highly targeted therapies need to
be combined and the cancers need to be
hit at multiple places at the same time
to try to prevent the development of
resistance similar to what's used now in
antimicrobial treatment that you would
treat a difficult bacteria like
tuberculosis for example with multiple
drugs at the same time
to prevent the development of resistance
one other issue is that
there are certain mutations
that
are found in multiple different cancers
so the same mutation for example in the
b raft gene
shown right here
for which there are drugs like
seraphinib
that will target the mutation in b raf
that will
really affect the growth of that tumor
unfortunately even though the same
mutations found in two different cancers
like melanoma and colon cancer the drug
is much more effective in melanoma than
it is in colon cancer and what this is
telling you is that
targeting just one pathway if that
cancer cell
has undergone
changes so that there are other
mutations driving that cancer that can
bypass
this particular step that even if you
inhibit that step you've bypassed it and
therefore the cancer
will not respond to that drug so
uh the two issues we need to really
focus on here is development of
resistance and bypassing the effect of
the drug
i'm going to
turn back to bryce now
thank you uh one other question from uh
from the audience that uh i'd like to
ask you spend a lot of time talking
about screening and uh we know there are
some screening programs already in place
like newborn screening
and then
you mentioned some of these carrier
screenings
some genes being more recommended than
others depending on
on what population you're talking about
where do you see the future of screening
do you see more screening for adult
conditions like
like cancer syndromes do you see
newborn screening expanding further to
include even more diseases um or do you
see screening even focusing on
you know new changes like you mentioned
uh that happened in the genome that
weren't inherited but
overall where do you see the future of
screening going
yeah that's a really uh it's an
interesting and important question and i
think
it's there is no one single answer to
that question go back to the acce
framework um i think that what you'd
want to do is set up screening in such a
way that you would be detecting
variants that have high positive
predictive value
so that
just by finding them you will know that
there is a significant
risk for disease and also that there
there's clinical utility
that knowing this uh is will be
important and therefore make the expense
of doing screening because remember when
you do screening you're doing generally
population screening so the number of
tests you have to do is really quite
high compared to diagnostic screening
we're only focusing on people who are
who have a particular disorder
i think that the future of preconception
screening is very great uh i i as the
cost of sequencing goes down the ability
to look at
essentially every disease every gene in
which mutations can cause disease when
you inherit two mutations one from each
parent i i don't think in that it's
going to be that far in the future when
such a screening test
in a cost-effective way is going to be
offered
to every uh
couple that's contemplating having
having a pregnancy and what will be
looked at will be genes that we know
mutations cause disease and we'll be
looking only at those mutations that we
know cause disease remembering the
variants of uncertain significance are
going to bedevil us for quite a while
until we have that worked out of course
preconception count testing is not going
to help with new mutations and so
this enters into a
uh much more
ethically fraught area uh that i don't
think we as a society have really uh
grappled with
and that is screening um
prenatally
uh
while widely we are screening prenatally
now
for certain classes of birth defects in
particular chromosome abnormalities
and the development of non-invasive
prenatal screening being able to
identify fetuses that are carrying extra
copies of chromosomes 13 18-21 by
testing the mother's blood for cell-free
dna is exploding as as an area of great
interest as a screening test and i think
that that is
that's not in the future that's here now
and the ability to do prenatal screening
is only going to be expanding to more
and more serious birth defects i think
the the the issue that
uh really bedevils us in that area is
this whole idea of screening for
non-medical traits
which by the way is also going on now
the screening that's being done for sex
of the fetus
and we already see certain societies
where the sex ratio the male to female
birth rate is shifting there are many
more males being born than before
compared to females because of prenatal
identification of female fetuses and
determination of female fetuses because
of social reasons that people believe
that females are less valuable than
males this is a very serious and to me
extremely troubling development of the
application of screening and i would
hate to see prenatal screening
expand along those lines as a pair as
opposed to expanding on the lines of
trying to prevent
serious debilitating and life
limiting
illness
so i
i finally screening for adult disorders
there's already now a discussion going
on in israel about
screening for hereditary breast and
ovarian cancer there there are three
particular variations in these two genes
that are responsible for the vast
majority of hereditary breast and
ovarian cancer and it's present in a few
percent of the population not one in 500
the way it is in a general population
such as the united states and so
uh
i think what you're seeing there is an
argument and not not about should
screening be done so much as
is it cost effective and is it useful
and i think as more and more
as the cost of screening goes down and
as our ability to intervene in these
disorders improves we're going to see
more and more adult screening
going on in in this
in society but once again please
remember the acce
framework
that is a discipline
when thinking about these that you
should always apply and i think with
that i'm going to have to call it quits
for the morning and thank you all for
your attention
and i hope you enjoy the session
thank you very much for attending this
session it was a pleasure to listen to
uh dr nussbaum
um
if
anyone attending this has further
wanted to discuss this further i believe
that the bioconference has a forum where
attendees can discuss amongst themselves
and i hope this was enlightening to you
i certainly enjoyed it and good luck
enjoy the rest of the conference
you